what's going on there reject nation as
doctor stranger the multiverse of
madness is coming out next week we were
waiting for some clips and we got our
first official club battle with
gargantos let's get to it leave a like
if you can also subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our review for doctor strange part two
is up here on the channel
[Music]
damn that looks great
ha ha how cool
oh
wow nice
oh
hmm
bad ass
who the hell are you yeah
what's great about that clip is
it's easy to forget that there's like
actual civilians and people sometimes in
these movies you know this clip you know
brings you back to more of that
traditional marvel vibe of just a hero
in new york city helping us save the day
i love all like the bewilderment
that doctor strange is doing because
like a benedict cumberbatch's
performance while he's also engaging in
this fight he also has that puzzled look
on his face the whole time of what the
hell's going on i'm trying to process
everything who's this girl why she's so
important why is this creature after
this girl he's trying to map this all
out and he's not even like looking at
the civilians around him we're all
panicking but i love how that creates
that like fear and terror this felt like
you know sam raimi spider-man and that
and that vibe of there's a battle
happening in new york city and there's a
whole bunch of people on the ground
floor who are all freaking out screaming
who are observing trying to get away but
can't that has that sam raimi
cinematography flair to it i thought it
was awesome yeah that was awesome
absolutely that those like you know
dutch coverage angles and i mean his
movies his spider-man movies were so
good at balancing yeah all the spectacle
but never forgetting the fact that you
have these people on the ground who the
whole point is to make sure that they're
okay and yeah i love that sort of
relatability that that brings you know
because strange is so in control he has
all this you know broad and mystical and
incredible power and so to watch him in
a situation where he's like okay i gotta
take care of this while also observing
as much as i can and figuring it out on
the fly i imagine this comes from pretty
early on in the movie this might even be
where he meets america chavez so like to
have yeah i don't think he knows who she
is at that point yeah so you can only
imagine you know there'll probably be
some kind of humorous introductory to
happen right after this but even just to
see the extrapolation on what we've
already seen with the you know big
mystical saw blade and gargantos but
seeing the reveal and how doctor strange
needs to like manipulate you know the
what's visible through time and space to
be able to see the entity to see the
creature and then to be able to fight it
and i love like how he kaleidoscopes out
the bus and stuff like that like it made
a scene that we're already really
familiar with feel that much more
imaginative and vital so i'm really
excited yeah i thought the effects were
awesome too the only time the effects
look a little bit off in this clip and
i'm wondering if it'll look a little
different in the theaters because
knowing marvel they're still working on
the visual effects even though the
movie's coming out next week but the
only time it looked like a little bit
goofy was when the cloak of levitation
captured chavez and carried her over to
him that was the only time like a little
bit off but for the amount of visual
effects that are in this one clip alone
this is just a snippet of what is going
to be probably a bigger and longer
action scene and even like gargantos
especially or even with the bus
kaleidoscope that you're referencing
those effects are just so awesome so
everything about here feels like they
shot it on the actual streets and then
they implemented the effects later and i
don't even know if that's the case
that's what it feels like you know i
don't know if that's true
but i like that it feels like they
actually shot this in new york when
maybe this is all just some sound stage
which makes it even that much more
impressive actually yeah absolutely and
two i mean it's a broad daylight effect
they're not hiding it in the dark in the
shadows so you gotta give them that too
is you know it's a full spectacle and
everybody on hand to make this look as
good as possible kind of shot and i yeah
at least so far you know if all we're
griping about is that you know cape gag
i'm sure they could probably improve on
that at least for the home video release
and yeah i really do love like the
colors of this you can really feel that
sam raimi color and contrast where
everything's just popping a lot more
we've seen so much of the mcu take place
on the streets of new york and so i like
that you do get more of that different
flair and i can only imagine with the
imax cameras that they shot this way to
actually watch this on imax just how
much more the cinematography is really
gonna just pop that much more and i'm
sure they'll be here with some of the
scenes in this film but what i
appreciate about this clip was i
normally feel like you know with these
big fights out in the streets of new
york you probably get a lot more of that
classic marvel quipping and yet you
didn't really get that here at all
actually now i think about it you didn't
get any of that this whole performance
of doctor strange as he's going through
this it's all just internal and i think
that's why i was admiring it so much
because you could feel a lot of the
performance going on and just his
expression in his body language as he's
being so observant towards this and
they're not relying on it being funny
they're allowing the situation to
actually be intense for the characters
while dealing with something so massive
unlike you know the likes of which i
mean poor new york poor new york and the
marvel cinematic universe the amount of
[ __ ] they gotta deal with all the time
they're always rebuilding right after
being completely destroyed yeah yeah and
i mean i i do i do really like that for
doctor strange because he is such an
omnipotent character that here yeah it
almost seems like they're doing a lot of
subtle tricks to really put you in his
perspective and really puts you in the
struggle that he's gonna face and yeah i
like that it's not he's still he could
have easily been standing there firing
quips off up at you know uh gargantos
that he's not gonna hear but yeah i like
that they played this a little bit more
like no watch him assess watch him you
know try and crack the situation and i
hope that you know plays in throughout
the movie it seems like this is a mess
largely of his creation to some variety
to some extent and so yeah to go along
with doctor strange in a position where
he is kind of uh not shamed but yeah
responsible for all this chaos you know
i think is a good place to bring an
entry point back into your character
well looking at the other trailers what
i've been theorizing because i haven't
been keeping up to date with plot leaks
what i've been theorizing is that i
imagined defender strange and america
chavez on the run that you see in some
of the other trailers that that will be
probably the prologue or the beginning
of this movie and that our doctor
strange is going to be able to see or
experience these memories so i imagine
that when he sees america chavez here
that look that he's giving is that's the
girl from the visions that i was having
as the other doctor strange you know so
i think that's just going to add that
much more intensity and i feel like
there's going to be a lot of chatter
about america chavez specifically you
know they don't really show her a lot in
the trailers but she's such a vital and
important character to this film and i
think she's going to be a major takeaway
so i'm hoping that in a film with
presumably a bunch of cameos and with a
bunch of characters and a bunch of
traveling the multiverse that this
newcomer
who
had to be taken out of spider-man no way
home and now introduced here i'm hoping
that she sochi gomez is able to really
shine in this film and that a lot of the
praise goes towards her all right guys
well dr strange the multiverse of
madness i'm sure they're only showing
clips from very early on in the film
they showed 20 minutes at cinemacon guys
what did you think about it leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell leave a like we'll catch you all
soon
[Music]